there's a bird strike on the plane does
that happen often yeah it's a series
they damaged the the engine and they
made it seem like it's a serious exactly
a serious issue i've hit birds um i've i
know someone that took a turkey vulture
to the face
through the cockpit right shattered the
cockpit knocked him out
um i think that
it actually i don't know him personally
about the story i know from uh the
command i was at and uh i believe the
backseater had to punch out
and punch them both out because he was
unconscious you know in the front seat
from the bird
um it can kill you from hitting you it's
you know it's like a bowling ball going
250 miles an hour
it can take out an engine uh
very easily
every airport i've flown at in the navy
i've had to check the the bird condition
if you will to see how many birds i've
we've had to cancel flights because of
because there's too many of them around
the airport some airports even have bird
radars no tear reports there are systems
that monitor the bird condition there is
yeah there's actual radar systems and
you can go in the um certain bases you
have to call up and they'll tell you
what it is for the day or for that hour
and other ones have it in like their
their weather report that goes out with
the radio
what are some technological solutions to
this or is this just
uh
because it's a low probability event
there's no real solution for it i would
say it's not a little probably develop
event i mean this is happening a lot i
mean although the hits themselves aren't
necessarily that common or i'll say a
catastrophic hit either a near miss or a
hit or the pilot having to actively
maneuver to avoid it is pretty common
and in fact it seems stressful it is
it's so common in fact that we know that
you never want to try to go over or you
never want to go under a bird if you see
it in front of you you always want to
try to go over it because what they'll
do immediately if they see you is and
you startle vegetables they'll bring
their wings in and just drop straight
down to try to get out of the path it's
interesting i didn't know they did that
but so if you immediately if you try to
go under them they're gonna be dropping
into you so you typically want to try to
go above them is it something you can
train for or no um
is this one of those things you have to
really experience it's a skill set that
um you somewhat trained for
in the duties of being a fighter pilot
in a sense right being able to react to
your environment very quickly and make
make decisions quickly so is that one of
the more absurd things
challenges you have to deal with in
flying is there other things sort of
maybe weather conditions
like harsh weather conditions is there
something that would maybe don't often
think about in terms of
the challenges of flying birds in a way
aren't a ridiculous threat for us it's
it's
a safety threat that you know anything
physical in the air is something that we
really have to be careful about whether
we're flying formation off of the
aircraft right next to us or whether
uh it's a turkey vulture at two thousand
feet or a flock of five thousand birds
like at the runway we have to wave off
you know and
although they're low probability a lot
of bases will have like actual
environmental protection agency
employees that are responsible for
safely removing migratory birds or
different animals
that may be in the runways or flying
about
wow i didn't know what a turkey vulture
is and it really does look like a mix
between a vulture and a turkey
and look kind of dumb no offense to
turkey vultures
you